oh to be honest i don't remember what
happened
so did he miss the boxes he did
why does chuck norris work so well why
do we remember it so fondly
looking at this fight scene what are the
critiques you have for it
that's why wow
thanks to skillshare for sponsoring this
video stick around at the end and see
how you can get one month free
skillshare premium what's up everybody
welcome back to another episode of
stuntman react we are joined by a
longtime
friend and the man who's worked with us
many times i'm not talking about ghee
i'm talking about malaya here so malai
has been in a ton of corridor videos and
has gone off and worked on a bunch of
cool projects as well
i am a fight choreographer i actually
started with my stunt team emc monkeys
we had a youtube channel which we worked
a lot with uh corridor i'm glad to be
back
in this familiar space even though it's
changed a lot yeah
ghee is joining us as well because we
just need that flavor in our
little show here i'm the little
salt
[Laughter]
so uh malai you and a bunch of the emc
guys
worked on iron fist right we did now
iron fist wasn't necessarily the most
uh critically well received marvel
series
it was not just know that i we had no
power
uh coordinator didn't have any say a lot
of the times when we see like action
sequences or some sequences that
you're like oh that's really janky a lot
of the times it's not because of the
stunt performers
it takes a team to make a film
let's start the characters in black at
night
with swords that are also black at night
yeah also i would argue that over the
shoulder is not a very good angle for
sword fights no no no no
like look at this combo you see the one
stab at this like you can't see any of
that
very not hitting me in my leg better not
hit me in my leg
he's already looking at it he's gonna
come right here
they're always surprised it's like we
were in a sword fight
man i can just see the director
photography being like how do i film
this blood how do i show blood how do i
how can i make this blood show up on
camera it's night time and it's raining
everything's already wet
everything's already black
so looking at this fight scene what are
the what are the critiques you have for
it
so what was missing was there's a lot of
moments in the fight that didn't capture
story-wise
[Music]
it's just all you see is a fight not a
well-captured fight
so working on television my experience
has been that there's barely
any time how many sessions did you guys
get with the actual actors to work on
this fight
like one one session it's not even a
full day because they gotta they gotta
go to a script reading dialect coach
fitness coach so they're doing all this
stuff on top of learning the
choreography
that's a lot of work yeah yeah it's not
like they shot the dialogue then the
next day we shot the fight it was
dialogue all right we have six hours
left now let's do the fight scene okay
we're gonna break for lunch and after
that we're gonna get into the fight
let's throw in another sword fight scene
that you've done that is
extra impressive because malai can't see
anything while doing that
let's go to the far cry blood dragon
my eyes are that's my in the robot suit
my vision was
this up here and then these two ones
down here
yeah just a little circle like this
[Music]
oh a little elevation a little twist
yeah so the swords that these guys are
using it's aircraft aluminum there's
actually a dude out in the desert in la
here
that makes film weapons out of aircraft
aluminum
aircraft aluminum is really light and
really strong if you try to do
this with like a cheap sword you get on
ebay the metal is going to snap
and then to get the swords to glow we
actually have them covered with
retroreflective tape basically the same
thing you wear in like safety vests and
then there's a ring light on the camera
but it's also on zinn's costume it's on
malaise costume so
it makes all of them glow with these
cool edges
so this was a fight that they wanted to
shoot as a master
oh no so master just means it's an
established shot
from the beginning to the end the whole
thing the whole thing
film
yeah because i don't know what i want
that's that's the old-school way of
shooting
especially for fight scenes like you
just kind of shoot coverage and figure
out later i'm like no you need to figure
out now because you're telling the story
right you got to tell these moments get
those those are more important
instead of wasting time so these are
masters here
this was a two minute fight and then
they added it to a one minute fight
it took out so much again yeah my jump
spin kick was trash because i was so
tired
as a stunt performer first step is don't
make me do masters
[Laughter]
so when would it be justified to do a
master never
never unless you're gonna use it as a
wonder unless you're gonna do that as a
winner
yeah when you're shooting a master it's
a sign that you didn't necessarily go as
far as you could of to having your fight
scene prepped
shooting all of your fight scene in
masters is definitely not going to yield
you a good result
you should be going in and breaking it
into your inserts and your sequences
guys nico's always sitting here talking
a big game about stunts and whatnot i
mean
have you even ever seen him do any cool
stunts well
stay tuned tomorrow because we literally
got a billion cardboard boxes so that
niko can prove his street cred and jump
off of this building yeah that's right
he literally jumps off this building
that video comes out tomorrow stay tuned
maybe even subscribe in
three two one action
oh oh that inside shot you took the
whole
windshield i did did it hurt going
through that windshield uh
to be honest i don't remember what
happened
all i remember was i'm on the floor that
was that was the last thing and holding
onto my gun
hey you didn't let go of the gun look at
the gun yeah i remember uh if you watch
when you hit the car
your gun goes and bonks you in the
forehead that happens
and you had a little cut on your eyebrow
you don't remember
i mean this is one of the easier car
hits just because i didn't have to take
a full-on hit
right i threw myself into the car so
you're launching yourself into that
windshield
is the intention just to break it so it
actually softens the impact a little bit
or is it just to make it crazy
i just want to go hard i think the one
thing that people forget about stunts is
you can't
go half-assed you must go full ass
because you will end up hurting yourself
if you bail it's way more dangerous to
build than it is to fully commit yeah
when you're standing on the street
corner waiting to cross and you see
traffic going by do you ever think to
yourself
if that car lost control and came
straight for me
here's how i would oh yeah there was one
time where i was just walking down the
street and a car
came at me like really fast but he was
parallel parking but he wasn't slowing
down fast enough
so i'm like oh [ __ ] so i just jumped but
he parked
was
so this is sleeping dogs clint's not
here but malaia's doing it
you know we're talking about it sorry
clint go watch it on his channel at
punisher
malai and the rest of the emc team put
together some bang and action here
clint wanted to break a lot of props for
this scene so i'm like okay let's break
some stuff
oh nice there's malai yeah messing up
zinn
dude packs up
all right into the kitchen there's my
lie
oh yeah i love that shot that was a one
shot oh one big shot also
oh dang that looks so good
inspiration from the raid
so did he miss the boxes he did we uh
we had too many guys on the line way
over
was was there a pad at the end there was
we had eight inches for him maybe you
guys did that to me once for a nerf
video you were making you did i was
surprised at how much force
you get out of just like a dude or two
just yanking a rope yeah
it's like you just let yourself go limp
and give yourself up to fate
there's a lot of trust in stunt work
like a lot of trust
yeah yeah it's crazy that's what a
coordinator told me he was like hey
you become a stunt man when you are
putting your life
in in the hands of the coordinator and
then your coordinator the moment a
stuntman is putting his life in your
hands
watches in his face watch what he does
with his mouth
question how long did you guys rehearse
the fight scene
not at all right you just showed up we
did like hong kong style we
choreographed and shot as we went
yep wow i think in hong kong they still
do that they don't prep
they just go in and they just shoot and
guys will just be chilling and waiting
and you know getting paid
whereas now you prep the work because
you don't pay a full crew you just pay
a number of stunt guys and then you
transfer that to the real shoot
this scene here i don't know if you guys
seen ninja 2
scott atkins yeah this fight scene was
stolen
um by a fight choreographer out in
thailand and it's replicated it's on our
channel we did a side-by-side
video and you can see the comparison
they modified it here and there but it's
very
it's even the shots are the same
people don't realize moves don't have to
connect in a real world you can do
whatever you want so this part where he
has
tuned his hands the hook is in his hands
how did they get onto other guys wrists
it doesn't matter you just you get there
you get there right
you just need to like flow that motion
into something that's just motion
and out of cut you can be doing whatever
you want as long as the motion flowed
same with the
when the two guys twist and falls the
motion is different but as long as
they're moving
it connects right into the wreck
right there let's go that must have
taken forever
yes i think jackie's expression there
tells me that he tried a lot
of takes here finally got it
singing in the rain yeah
he always like uses the environment so
creatively it's so fun
like this is the closest to like actual
jackie style stuff that you'll see in an
american film yeah like it's way more
jacky than rush hour it's way more
the sad thing about rush hour was like
you know they wanted him because of all
rumble bronze and stuff and they're like
oh we're gonna we're gonna hire you but
we're not gonna let you do what you
normally do
right i think a part of why i've liked
jackie so much is because i still get
the feeling like he
likes what he does because all the
little touches in the fight scene
don't really happen if you're not
enjoying what you do
like the little funny ideas you can't
come up with those if you're just
so a style of scene i would love to
react to a little bit more are one takes
so if you have like a long one take
fight scene please leave a
recommendation down below so we can take
a look at those
don't say the hallway scene from old boy
we already reacted to that but you know
anything else
[Music]
in my childhood on the usa channel
it's been it's been a long time coming
why does chuck norris work so well
why do we remember it so fondly 1978
world champion he fought the dragon man
yeah right that too like this is around
the time when steven seagal films were
pretty big too
they're almost the exact same thing
we got this and you've got that
kind of reminds me of power rangers
because they're in the park
[Laughter]
[Music]
is he just does he just have his gun in
his belt yeah
no holster jeremy's doing the same combo
which is punch to the gut
punch to the face after the typical
combo
but you know what that's what you're
gonna do your first time as a stunt guy
for the most part you're gonna play a
goon
you gotta throw a right hook and you
gotta take a heavy reaction and hit the
ground
back when i first started i thought
doing stunts was like i'm being like a
bunch of jackie chan style film just
doing hello fights
no here's a gun you're gonna shoot at
the good guy
you're gonna get shot and you're gonna
go down and we'll probably cut before
you hit the ground yeah
right but you should sell it still
[Music]
there it is crescent cake so is this a
real move
uh yeah yeah but no one really uses it
he's doing it
i mean that's a chuck kick maybe maybe
it worked for him back in the tournament
days
[Music]
were you breaking into the military
into a military compound dude they're
like spin kicks
fried cake that's a good sidekick
whoever did that sidekick that was nice
dude he's just messing these guys up one
man army
the theatrics are there like i'm feeling
the vibe like it's a brawl and he's just
like beating him up it's just boom boom
you know
it's like playing street fighter 2
so you got two punch moves and two kick
moves
i've been waiting for you oh [ __ ] gary
bucy
what's up
[Music]
every time they're losing in a fist
fight they decide to pull a weapon on
this man
[Music]
oh dang let's triple cross how's that
hella triple cut
you know if chuck norris hadn't actually
been like a karate champion
i don't think the show would have worked
i think he needed a little bit of that
like cred
that street cred like let people be like
okay i'll you know i'll tune in for the
fights
so if you're watching this video chances
are you enjoy learning new things about
life and perhaps filmmaking well thanks
to the online learning community of
skillshare there are thousands of
classes that you can choose from to
expand your mental horizons
skillshare is curated specifically for
learning meaning that there's no ads
around there
they're always launching new premium
classes as well you can learn everything
from cooking
to after effects any type of 3d program
drone flying photography
for instance there is a productivity
master class from ali abdal his class is
called principles and tools to boost
your productivity i mean this dude's a
doctor
he runs a youtube channel a podcast he
does a whole bunch of stuff and yet he's
able to do it all while maintaining a
social life
i'm always wanting to do more things in
life and it's hard to fit all of that
into my time so maybe a little bit of
productivity
learning will go a long way skillshare
actually has these live courses as well
so you can work alongside fellow members
as a teacher
live streams their course to you for
less than 10 bucks a month with an
annual subscription
you can maybe throw some of the money
that you would towards like a streaming
platform and more towards something that
will actually improve your brain
so kevin get off that toilet and sign up
for skillshare.com
click that link in the description the
first 1 000 people to click the link
will get an
entire month for free to skillshare
premium that's a pretty good deal if i
don't say so myself
that was fun watching all those again
right it's been a while since i just sat
down and watched just fight scene
i know it's that's actually one of my
favorite things about this show is just
sitting down watching yeah
revisiting all the scenes man if you
guys want to check out more of malai's
work
follow him on instagram it's at
malayastunkai
or on youtube which is just simply
malaya kim is his channel we'll have
links in the description below
gee also thank you once again for
joining us of course you guys can follow
gui
all right dudes thank you thanks for
watching everybody
[Applause]
you